MAGAZINE ENTITLED WHEN DOES
EVERYONE BECOME A SOCIALIST.
WE KNOW SOCIALISM DOESN'T WORK.
THE PROMISE IS IT WILL TAKE AWAY
ALL OF YOUR FEARS.
EVERYTHING WILL BE FREE.
IT'S MEANS GOVERNMENT TAKE OVER
OF ENTIRE INDUSTRIES.
ONE EXAMPLE IS HEALTHCARE.
KAMALA HARRIS AND OTHERS
GILLIBRAND, YOU WON'T BE ALLOWED
TO OWN YOUR OWN PRIVATE
HEALTHCARE PLAN.
THEY SAID SO.
HOW MUCH DO YOU WANT TO BET
DEMOCRATS EXEMPT THEMSELVES AND
KEEP IT.
THE PLAN IS PUSHED BY BERNIE
SANDERS, KAMALA HARRIS,
ELIMINATES ALL PRIVATE HEALTH
SORRINESS.
-- HEALTH INSURANCE.
WITH SOCIALISM EVERYTHING IS
FREE.
THEY NEVER KEEP THAT PROMISE.
LIKE KEEP YOUR DOCTOR AND KEEP
YOUR PLAN AND PLAY LESS.
YOU GIVE UP FREEDOM AND LIBERTY
IN THE NAME OF FALSE SUTER.
-- SECURITY.
ONE PUSHING THIS IS ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
AND PATRICK MOORE IS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF GREENPEACE CANADA
AND WROTE THIS ON TWITTER.
POMPOUS LITTLE TWIT YOU DON'T
HAVE A PLAN TO GROW FOOD FOR 8
BILLION PEOPLE WITHOUT FOSSILE
FOODS OR GET FOOD TO SEE?
WITH WHAT HORSES?
YOU WOULD BRING ABOUT MASS
DEATH.
PATRICK MOORE JOINS US WITH THE
CHIEF METEOROLOGIST JOE.
THEY ARE GOING AFTER YOUR
CREDENTIALS AT GREENPEACE WHICH
HAS HAD A STELLAR REPUTATION.
I AM AN ALL OF THE ABOVE GUY AND
BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE GOOD
STEWARDS OF GOD'S GIFT.
THAT'S ALL OF THE ABOVE.
WHY DID YOU SAY THAT ON TWITTER?
>> SHE IS TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND SAYING WE HAVE TO
ELIMINATE ALL FOSSIL FUEL
SENSOR, COAL, OIL AND NATURAL
GAGS.
THIS WOULD BE SUICIDE.
OVER 80% OF THE WORLD'S ENERGY
COMES FROM FOSSILE FUEL SENSOR.
-- FUELS.
I SEE AOC RECRUITING YOUNG
TEACHERS AND YOUNG CHILDREN
AGAINST THE APOCALYPSE THEY ARE
SAYING.
THEY ARE TELLING CHILDREN THERE
WILL BE AN APOCALYPSE IN 10
YEARS IN THEY DON'T SAVE THE
CLIMATE.
I THINK IS CHILD ABUSE MYSELF.
THE WHOLE CLIMATE CHANGE
MOVEMENT REVERTED TO USING KIDS
AS A FRONT FOR NOT ONLY CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ENDING THE USE OF
FOSSILE FUEL SENSOR BUT THE
WHOLE BALL OF WAX ABOUT
SOCIALISM.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
TELL.
>> Sean: THERE WAS A CUTE GIRL
ON "60 MINUTES" SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR 4 YEARS.
AS I LISTENED, SHE BELIEVES
EVERYTHING.
I AGREE IN THE SENSE IT'S
APOCALYPTIC.
JOE IS, ONE THING I LOVE ABOUT
YOU, YOU CAN TELL ME WHAT WAS
THE BIG STORM IN 1903 AND WHAT
CAUSED IT TO HAPPEN.
YOU SAID THE SAME THING AS
PATRICK MOORE.
>> WELL, YEAH.
1903 ATLANTIC CITY WAS HIT BY A
HURRICANE.
>> Sean: SHOW OFF.
>> WHEN I SAW THE NEW GREEN DEAL
I THOUGHT IT WAS A "SATURDAY
NIGHT LIVE" SKIT.
WE WILL BUILD RAILROADS ACROSS
THE OCEAN.
BUILD ONE TO THE MOON.
GREAT FOOD BUT NO ATMOSPHERE.
IT'S MEANT TO GET YOU FIGHT
AGAINST AN EXTREME POSITION.
HE JUST DESCRIBED IT.
THEY ARE INDOCTRINATING KIDS.
WHERE WOULD THOSE KIDS BE
WITHOUT FOSSILE FUEL?
THE LIFE EXPECTANCY AND THE GDP
ARE SKY ROCKETING.
IT'S LIKE THESE PEOPLE ARE
UNGRATEFUL FOR WHAT GOT THEM
HERE.
>> YOU THINK ABOUT ELIMINATE
COWS AND CARS.
AIRPLANES, HOW ARE WE GOING TO
GET TO EUROPE?
TAKE A SAILBOAT?
A HIGH SPEED TRAIN.
>> A TRAIN!
>> Sean: MY QUESTION, PATRICK,
ISN'T NATURAL GAS ONE OF THE
CLEANER BURNING GASESES.
WEREN'T THERE WAYS TO IMPROVE
THE ENVIRONMENT SIMULTANEOUSLY
USING THE LIFEBLOOD OF EVERY
ECONOMY THAT FEEDS EVERYBODY AS
YOU RIGHTLY POINT OUT?
>> WE HAVE IMPROVED THE
CLEANSINESS OF ALL OF THE
FOSSEILE FUEL SENSOR
FOSSEILE FUELS.ENSOR
WE COULD USE MORE NUCLEAR ENERGY
BUT THEY ARE AGAINST THAT TOO.
WE COULD PUT NUCLEAR REACTORS IN
THE BIG SHIPS LIKE THE RUSSIANS
NAVIES ARE POWERED.
WE COULD DO THAT.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSPORTATION AND ALSO
AGRICULTURE, FOOD AND MOVING
PEOPLE AND GOODS AROUND.
IF YOU STOP MOVING THE FOOD INTO
THE CITIES, PEOPLE IN THE CITIES
WILL STARVE.
THEY CAN'T GROW THEIR FOOD IN
MANHATTAN.
>> Sean: NOT ENOUGH TOMATO
POTTS.
JOE, CLOSE US OUT.
>> IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ENTIRE HISTORY OF THE PLANET,
THE 10 MILLION YEARS, THIS WOULD
BE THE FIRST TIME THAT MAN IS
CONTROLLING THE CLIMATE.